cette réunion là aujourd'hui arrive à
une étape majeure du chantier alors que
à peine deux ans c'est pas grand chose
nous sépare de la réouverture vous avez
avancé la date du 8 décembre
2024 c'est l'archevêque de Paris qui a
articulé pour la première fois je crois
dans les médias cette date mais c'est
effectivement la date vers laquelle nous
nous aurions aujourd'hui donc après le
temps de la sécurisation de l'édifice
puis de la préparation de la
restauration c'est l'époque où j'étais
venu vous l'avez rappelé en septembre
2021 c'est ça je crois oui c'est ça nous
sommes maintenant complètement et
pleinement dans les travaux effectifs de
la restauration et
l'intense l'intense activité qui règne
sur le chantier latex Notre-Dame de
Paris est vraiment en train de renaître
grâce à la mobilisation constante des
équipes de l'établissement public de la
maîtrise d'œuvre des entreprises que
nous avons sélectionné ces derniers mois
le chantier basse en plein conformément
au calendrier que nous avions fixé dès
le départ
le dynamisme des travaux produit ses
effets de manière très visible de
semaine en semaine la restauration des
intérieurs du monument rend d'ores et
déjà Notre-Dame la pleine beauté de ses
pierres nettoyées et l'État éclatantes
de ces décors peints dans les chapelles
de du cœur
il témoigne de l'engagement et de la
compétence que montre les entreprises
que nous avons sélectionnées les
compagnons les artisans d'art qui sont à
l'oeuvre dans la cathédrale et dans les
ateliers partout en France et pas
seulement sur l'île de la Cité
le bon aboutissement ça n'a pas été
mince des nombreux appels d'offres que
nous avons conduit depuis plus d'un an
près d'une centaine de marchés attribués
à ce jour la passion et la fierté il
faut souligner des compagnons que je
constate tous les jours sont les
meilleurs gages de réussite dont nous
pouvons disposer
comme je l'ai rappelé nous avons achevé
la première phase des travaux celle de
la sécurisation de la cathédrale à la
fin d'été le 21 nous l'avons achevé il
faut le noter dans le respect total du
Grand du calendrier que nous avions fixé
tout en restant en deçà en deçà de
l'enveloppe que nous avions fixée
150,3 millions d'euros pour une
enveloppe prévisionnelle de 165 millions
d'euros
cette phase est désormais loin derrière
nous je ne reviens pas car j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous la présenter en
détail
lors de ma dernière audition en
septembre
nous sommes donc dans une phase
particulièrement active avec la
réalisation des opérations préparatoires
à la restauration
désormais achevé et le travail d'appel
d'offre de travaux afin de sélectionner
en permanence les meilleurs entreprises